I wash my hands after I do anything but
girlfriends have gotten mad at me
because like refused to share a water
bottle with them
I really hate seeing gum I don't like
people to sit on my bed in their street
clothes
I won't eat anything if it's like even
close to the expiration date you know
you wash your hands you grab the paper
towel and then you grab the door now put
the paper towel and you leave and you
throw it
she's freshly bathed and she feels like
grimy to me God her breath is like if
this one's peeing
she tries to walk under to get peed on
she was rolling around a dead bird it
was like a dead bird carcass I got
pretty lucky with vicious because he's
not like a slobbery guy at all poop
grosses me out more than anything and
heats poop like all the time she licks
her parts and she puts her nose and
other dogs but I kind of think it's
reasonable to not want you know that on
my face it's gonna be pretty gross every
old dog deserves to be kissed you know
where is he where is he give me a kiss
you know
monkey
yeah you just did that that was a
completely grotesque experience I was
pretty foul what was my egg going
through my head while this is happening
was that I know she goes to the cat
litter box and post love turds out and
I'm just like why do you do this to me I
wish that he would have just grazed my
lips but it I could feel him trying to
just insert insert his tongue into my
mouth and that made it worse I mean a
lot of tongue and she sheds a lot too so
now we're just talking here all over my
face it's kind of sweet getting that
kind of love from an animal giving
pleasure is a certain kind of pleasure
and if I did that for monkey then I did
good today high five yeah
maybe once a year if you're good we'll
have a make-out session I gave Luca a
treat and she spit it out didn't want it
so she peed on it this one came up
without missing a beat and ate it
they're just monsters